alright one place now looking to swiftly
and strategically reopen businesses to
avoid another outbreak is the great
state of Texas joining us now with more
on that is governor Greg Abbott governor
you didn't get hit as hard as New York
it'll be easier I think for Texas but
it's still tricky especially when we get
to sporting events concerts restaurants
in particular we've got to be careful
how we do this what do you thinking
about doing well you're talking about it
Shawn in the exact right way and that is
listen we want to open Texans love to
work Texans are dying to get back to
work and we want them to get back to
work but we have to do so in a very safe
way so that we don't regenerate the
spread of the corona virus in the state
of Texas but we are working on
strategies as we speak with medical
experts with business leaders to find
the right strategy so that we can
unleash our kind of remember this Shawn
Texas was the number one state in the
United States for job creation last year
we're leading in gross domestic product
at Texas is essential for the future of
the United States of America
economically America needs Texas to get
back to business but I think most states
can reopen even sooner than later we
don't have to wait till May first but
it's gonna be more challenging in a city
like New York now I think there's a new
normal for New York I think you know
half the workforce should probably work
from home if they can I think the issue
of gloves and masks that'll be part of
it I think taking the temperature
without touching anybody that'll be part
of it maybe testing will be part of it
but again medical privacy is important
we don't need a database but people that
have to know if they're positive how did
they contact maybe other people they got
into contact contact tracing we call it
so you're talking about all the right
things and here's the deal what we've
learned over the past two months is
there are certain strategies that have
worked because there have been some
businesses that have been open while at
the same time we've been reducing the
spread of the corona virus so we need to
learn from these strategies about what
worked and allow other businesses to
deploy those strategies while we are
ensuring that we continue to
the spread of the coronavirus all right
governor we're cheering for Texas you
could lead the way and I'm sure you will
as you often do thank you for being with
us